hey guys what's up i'm so excited for
you to watch this interview before we
get into this interview i want to talk
about our sponsor
prime xbt if you're trading bitcoin
you got to be using primex bt not only
do they have global markets
available to anyone but they also have
great execution
low fees and an amazing user interface
the best part about primex bt is that
you can also follow some of the best
traders in the world
you go on you find someone who you think
is smart and you can literally just
follow their trades when they execute
something your portfolio executes the
same
and if you think you're one of the best
traders in the world then you can simply
go on there and have people follow you
and you earn a little extra income by
having those followers
so if you're trading bitcoin anywhere in
the world you got to use primex bt
they've won multiple awards for being
one of the best trading platforms
in crypto you can trade spot markets or
even use margin
so go on over to use primexpt you can go
to the description and click on the link
there
all right let's get into this episode
today i really hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang got jp here
with me thank you so much for doing this
man
hey thanks a lot palm for having me on
absolutely i'm super excited to
go over all this stuff let's just start
with your background uh before you ever
knew what bitcoin cryptocurrencies were
uh where were you born where did you
grow up and kind of what you do
yes let me just start with our with our
name exodus i think it's really
important for the listeners is that
our name exodus is an escape
from the traditional financial system
and the reason
that that is so important is because
money
the most important commodity is
controlled by centralized institutions
and so we felt the need to build
software to empower people to control
their own wealth and to date we have a
million customers and we're on track to
do
100 million dollars in revenue this year
and if you contrast that
to where i was in 2015 it was broke i
only had a few thousand dollars
in my checking account there's kind of a
little funny story
surrounding this that um i had this old
shitty toyota camry
her name was goldie and she was sitting
outside the front of my house
and the car got hit twice
in the same day and the insurance
company didn't love goldie as much as i
love goldie
and you know i was fortunate enough that
that money
that the insurance company paid out gave
me a little bit of fuel
to survive to actually raise money for
exodus
but before all that my background is i'm
a software
engineer born and raised in nebraska
and you know i witnessed what happened
with the financial crisis
and um you know in the transition there
and then
into mount gox and the failures with
mount gox and how it was
difficult to use and it wasn't safe
or secure and so this is kind of the
origin of how this all got started
yeah and so let's talk a little bit
about kind of growing up in the midwest
uh most people who listen to this are
going to be either international or live
on one of the coasts
but uh when you think about the midwest
uh kind of childhood what are some of
the things that stick out to you as
advantages having grown up there yeah so
the midwest is really known for having a
strong work ethic and and that's how a
lot of people around here are people
work
really hard but we knew that uh to build
a company
that has a decentralized future
that we were going to have to build a
company that is 100
remote and pays salaries 100
in bitcoin and that was one of our
secret weapons early on is that we were
allowed
we were able to despite the fact that my
co-founder uh
daniel who is the design guru early on
he's got design
experiences from disney apple bmw nike
and louis vuitton to name a few
and um knowing that early on that
we wanted to build a tech company
quickly and so
we're like let's pay salaries in bitcoin
and uh
100 of the salaries and we could recruit
from all of the world and that's how we
got started
and that's how we were able to move so
quickly yeah and so what was the
original impetus for
uh exodus like what was the idea how did
you come up with it and
how did you get started yeah so
with watching again with like mount gox
and
how difficult it was to use and knowing
that it
it's not safe because you know the hacks
and then seeing that
you know the biggest companies coin
based finance they're all
centralized and we saw we see a future
where
it's completely decentralized and so
that's where this
this really started i actually built a
bitcoin wallet
uh called coinbolt and it was in the
early days back in 2014 i quit my day
job at a biotech company
and i was pitching coinbolt and somebody
told me that it looked like
basically a five-year-old designed it
and i knew that i needed to
uh to improve my my design abilities and
again
that's when i met daniel and he had that
same shared ethos
of let's build something that people can
control their own wealth
and we we did something different
because coinbolt was originally just on
the mobile phone
and we thought well let's actually build
exodus we know that people
love to manage a portfolio of of
cryptocurrency
people love to trade cryptocurrency
let's build it on the desktop because in
this moment time about 2015
is when uh most people were trading on
the desktop and so that's where we got
started
our first investor eric voorhees a lot
of people don't know this at this moment
in time but
they've been in denver colorado which is
right next to nebraska
and it's about a you know seven or eight
hour drive so my co-founder daniel and i
we would get in the car we would drive
out to denver and we would sit with eric
and then we'd drive back in the same day
because we didn't have the money
to stay in a hotel and so that's that's
how we we got started here
i love it and so when you started uh you
guys wanted to build this desktop wallet
um where what did you build for was it
just bitcoin was it for kind of
all different types of assets how were
you thinking about that yeah so the
early version
was just bitcoin litecoin and dogecoin
and that's it and then because that's
really all there i mean there was a few
other ones like namecoin and maybe just
a few other ones
uh but yeah i remember one when dash was
released dash was
starting to become popular and then of
course ethereum that was one of the
biggest so
we brought in ethereum and dash real
quickly and those were the two assets
in 2017 it was actually february of 2017
it was just daniel myself and then a
couple other engineers
and we made three thousand dollars that
that month
february 2017 we're like uh we might
have a business
but it was then march of 2017
where we made 70 000 and we're like oh
yeah we got a business
and it was because of people's interest
in in dash and ethereum
yeah and when you think through kind of
the product suite today so you go from
uh kind of a single wallet type
functionality on desktop
uh that supports you know three or four
different cryptocurrencies to today
you've got an
entire ecosystem that you're building
out walk us through kind of that product
suite and what users can do with the
product
yeah so desktop is was the where it all
started and it's just
simply to send receive and exchange
cryptocurrency
and of course early on as you would
expect we got so
much demand for a mobile app and we knew
we would always build a mobile app
but we we thought let's build desktop as
a stable base because that's where
people are trading but over time
after we stabilized the back end
infrastructure we got to the 2017 bull
run
we stabilized the infrastructure we knew
that we had to bring in
additional features and and two of the
biggest ones is first of all
we brought in tracer support we knew
that there were a lot of people out
there
that wanted to secure their
cryptocurrency
in a way where they didn't have a worry
and they were very comfortable
with a hardware wallet so we brought in
tracer support and then around that same
time we also we also released the the
mobile app
and so this way allows people to view
their portfolio
on the go and um and today the product
suite has really evolved out into
we've started thinking about how can we
make it
easy for people to buy cryptocurrency
and so we introduced apple pay support
inside the mobile wallet and so a person
can download exodus
on the iphone and then they can have
bitcoin in their wallet
in less than two minutes and so that was
a that's a very big popular feature for
people
and then in addition to that there's a
lot of small things that people aren't
thinking about
that we've brought into exodus that are
really useful once people start using it
so a recent recent feature that was
introduced is
the the notion of having multiple
portfolios
on on the desktop and then actually have
it magically sync with with the mobile
and you can name a portfolio on on the
desktop and it magically shows up with
the same name
on on the the mobile and desktop and so
that's that's kind of what we we brought
in and and beyond that
we really are passionate about
eventually making d5
easy to use that's going to be really
important for the ecosystem
you know making nfts easy i mean nfts
are really hot and popular right now
but there's so on all these different
websites and still with the ethereum gas
fees it's still there's a lot of
complications
that's how we're thinking about making
easy views so jp one things i want to
talk about is you guys have kind of
three core
ideas um kind of as you guys keep
pushing forward and one of them is that
there's going to be continued
distrust in these centralized
institutions uh maybe help us understand
kind of
what you mean by that and how you see
that playing out
yeah absolutely so i mean if you go back
to the 2008 financial crisis
you had a majority of americans saying
let them fail let them fail and both
political parties went against the
american populace and were in support of
bailouts for these banks
and so i think that's where the origin
really started
and then if you look at the presidential
election of 2016 or the president-elect
presidential election of 2020 doesn't
matter which side you're on
either side thought the other side stole
the election and so
now you have a majority of people in
america who are starting to think
is is the electoral process in favor of
me as an american
i just saw a statistic yesterday it said
the first time
more than 50 percent of people identify
as independent
not either party and so then if we look
at uh kind of what happened with with
aws
and and some of the issues with with
parlor and if we look at
uh robin hood and gamestop i mean that
was the most recent one where people
were just like are you kidding me
are you kidding me that robin hood is
doing this and so
i think these sorts of things are going
to continue
and it's only going to cause more
distrust for people and not to mention
that the biggest and most obvious one is
the federal reserve
saying hey we're going to print 1.9
trillion dollars whether you like it or
not
and so people are starting to look for
alternatives and rightfully so
yeah and it feels like a lot of the
centralized entities part of the problem
is that they are human-led there's you
know emotion there's greed there's fear
uh there's just mismanagement and so uh
in a lot of these decentralized products
what you get is you just get algorithmic
governance right or or you get true
uh governance by the people and it feels
like that's just a
solution that people are getting more
comfortable with
absolutely yeah i completely agree with
that with the rise
of of defy right now it's still very
complicated
but there's so much interest in these
systems and protocols
because of the promise that they offer
if we take a look at
you know like the lending platforms
whether it's compound or ave
you know these things you know taking a
loan out on the blockchain is really
cool it's just difficult to use today
yeah and then when you start to think
through um kind of defy in general i
know another thing that you're really
focused on is the idea that
more and more people are going to flock
to decentralized financial applications
it sounds like you're probably less
religious about where exactly that's
going to happen from the kind of tribal
wars of different blockchains
uh but more so just like decentralized
financial applications will be the
standard they will become more popular
over time
and so you at exodus want to figure out
how to kind of serve as an interface
and a connectivity point to wherever the
market adopts those applications
that's exactly right so this last summer
we were we had a integration with
compound finance
and then sport x a lot of people haven't
heard the name sport x but it's a really
cool
decentralized betting platform sports
betting platform
and so we had integrations with both
these platforms
and they're both both built on ethereum
and so
you we all know what's happened with
ethereum and the rise of the gas prices
and it started to make if you're going
to put a 40 or 50
bet down in a game and you've got to pay
30 or 40 on gas fees
you're just not going to do it and so
for us you know
we don't have a a horse in the race
whether it's ethereum or some other
blockchain
but we just want a blockchain that
people
find useful and it's cost efficient and
it just works for for the average person
yeah one of the things that really
stands out about your product and i know
it's a third
focus for you is uh the user experience
right with the user interface
um it's absolutely gorgeous and i think
that uh it rivals what people would
expect in a non-crypto product right so
if you had a consumer product in the
traditional world that you looked at you
said wow that's really pretty
um i really like the way that it's so
intuitive and the way that it just works
um it seems like you guys have been able
to take the best of that design world
uh and bring it into uh crypto and the
bitcoin ecosystem where frankly a lot of
the design
leaves a lot to be desired in many cases
absolutely so everything that we do
we do with the product and customer
experience in mind
in fact there's a little story here that
kind of represents this we call this the
bar
test or the pub test and i remember back
in it was i think around 2017 or so a
friend
asked me like hey jp i want to get into
cryptocurrency
which wallet should i use and so at this
moment in time we didn't have a mobile
wallet but you know we're sitting in a
bar and we're having some drinks and i'm
like okay
let's start downloading mobile so we
started going one by one through all of
them
and all of them required a major
ceremony at the beginning to get started
write down your 12-word phrase and do
all kinds of things that a person in a
bar shouldn't have to do
and so we're thinking like okay let's
think about the product
experience let's think about the
customer experience how can we get a
person to get started as soon as
possible
and how beyond that how does a person
feel when they use the product and
that's what we call emotionally driven
design
when we think about feelings how person
feels when they use the product and you
can see that everywhere in the product
absolutely and so when you start
thinking through um
that product iteration moving forward
what are the things that you want to add
to it or improve over time
yeah so one of the things that we've
done recently is that we
this was just announced on friday we we
filed with the sec
so that we could offer our common stock
on the blockchain directly inside of
exodus
and so this allows a person to download
x's
share in our success and use and buy our
stock
only with cryptocurrency whether it's
bitcoin ethereum or usdc
and do this all within exodus and so why
this is so cool is that
we'll show the world that this works
well
i mean if you look at like the old ico
crowdfunding days like
eos raised four billion dollars on a
website
right and so if we can do this in an app
that already has
you know presumably billions of dollars
in it then uh
we should be able to be really
successful and then other companies
can come inside and and do a
crowdfunding option
right inside of exodus and then
everybody can trade their stock
we're going to do an integration with t0
and and merge
and this will allow us to effectively
have a global ipo
throughout the course of 2021. yeah and
so talk through a little bit more about
this right you have a business that um
was uh quite attractive uh through 2020
this year you're on track to do about a
hundred million dollars in revenue
uh i'm assuming that there will be
profit there off of that
and you're choosing to basically go to
your user base and say hey you as users
you should invest
rather than go to traditional venture
capitalists and so walk through kind of
a logic as to why go to the user base
uh kind of what the philosophical belief
that you have
uh as to not go to a venture capitalist
and kind of just turn to the community
yeah so venture capital it's a fine it's
a fine way to raise money
but in reality it's only reserved for
the privileged few who are accredited
investors or venture capitalists
and so we wanted to create a future
where anyone can participate whether
you're a credit investor or not a credit
investor
and beyond that we see a world where
a situation like what happened with
robin hood and gamestop
we see a world where that can't happen
if you have
stock in an application and you're not
happy with how that application is
working
you can just take your stock and go to
another platform much like how crypto
works today we want to bring that same
world to the world of of securities and
exchanges
now we understand it's going to be
difficult because there are so much
regulations surrounding here and we have
to follow all the regulations
but we believe by working with our
partners we can build a system
and uh where it's on smart contracts on
the blockchain
and we can give the same benefits for
customers to have that control
got it and so when you start to think
through um
kind of implications of this right
obviously one it provides a lot more
access to both accredited non-accredited
investors but
will every company go do this is there
some obstacle or barrier that makes it
hard for them to do it like how do you
just think of other companies and
whether they should pursue this
yeah so in the the 2012 jobs act there
are two provisions that make
this really lucrative for custom
companies so one of them is the
regulation a
plus offering that's what we're doing
it's a little more of an involved
process and
it costs about a million dollars or so
give or take to actually make this a
reality
and there's also the regulation cf
process
that allows smaller companies to get
started even sooner
and it's much cheaper now the regulation
a process allows a company to raise
up to 75 million dollars and the
regulation
cf process allows the company to raise
up to five million dollars
through pure crowdfunding so we see a
world where a lot of companies are going
to start doing this
and so when you look at this uh the
regulation
a plus allows 75 million dollars it's
accredited and non-accredited investors
but there's a couple of
um maybe uh kind of safeguards if you
will uh
put on these investors talk through for
those that are listening that may be
interested
what exactly are the kind of
requirements or safeguards
for those two investor types yeah so
as as a person would expect for
accredited investors
an accredited investor can invest as
much as they want
now the sec for non-accredited investors
has said that
they have a maximum non-credit investors
are allowed only to invest a maximum of
10 of their net worth
or 10 of their income and so that's one
of the safeguards that the sec has put
in place
amazing and so as we kind of continue to
see this
uh talk about the tokenization of the
shares as well right because one piece
of this is hey i'm gonna use existing
regulations that are in place and i'm
gonna use it to my advantage i'm gonna
go out i'm gonna raise capital
but now what you're talking about is
you're basically talking about uh on the
back and
tokenizing the shares rather than having
them uh done kind of the more
traditional way what is the advantage to
you to do this and what's the advantage
to the investor
yeah so the advantage to the investor
again for the future is
control and that and having those stocks
actually not have to worry if the system
goes down can take the stocks and go
go anywhere else it doesn't exist right
at this moment but that's an advantage
in the future
in the short term one of the other big
advantages is transparency
so the cap table becomes completely
transparent at least in how it's
distributed
amongst people but uh one of the things
that we're facing with
tokenizing on the blockchain is that we
were originally looking at ethereum
and we were said we were settled with
ethereum
and then we just found out a couple
weeks ago
that it was going to cost up to 9
million
dollars to issue our stock on ethereum
and that's due to the high gas prices
and so we're currently shopping around
for for other blockchains to do this
yeah and so when you think about um kind
of the tokenization
component are there issues there on the
regulatory front or still obstacles and
complexities you need to work through
or is it pretty straightforward in terms
of how regulators think about this and
kind of what they'll allow and they
won't allow
yeah there are definitely obstacles but
we're working with a great partner over
at securitize and what they've done is
they are a registered transfer agent
within license with the sec so that
means that they have the ability to do
this
and they have blend through a world of
smart contracts
and so there are challenges it's not as
easy as just
i'm gonna send um send my my shares to
somebody else that's not registered
in the securitized smart contract so
there's definitely challenges
and then it gets even more challenging
when we have to integrate this
technology
with uh other third parties like t0
which is a trading system or merge which
is a trading system
for people outside the united states and
so we have to integrate all three of
these systems together
while following the regulations and use
the these smart contracts
got it and so when you think about the
75 million dollars that's coming in
uh there's advantages to both you and to
the investor in terms of the way you're
doing it so both reggae plus and then
tokenization
uh but you still get 75 million dollars
right of equity capital
what are you gonna do with the money
yeah so the biggest thing that we're
gonna do is we're gonna we're gonna
reinvest in the product with like
everything that we do
and so we're gonna make the product so
that a person can buy
cryptocurrency anywhere in the world
because if our you know as our mission
is is to exit the traditional financial
system and help the world do that
we have to make it easy for a person in
any country in the world to
actually buy cryptocurrency whether
that's with a bank account whether
that's with the credit card and a lot of
people don't have bank accounts or
credit cards and so
we have to find ways to actually make it
legal and accessible for them to to do
this with cash
and so that's where a big use of the
money is going to go to
and then in addition to that you know
defy and making d5
really simple to use and uh you know
making nft
simple to use that's going to be a big
component
and then of course marketing and then
finally
uh there's going to be i think you'll
see some strategic acquisitions that
we'll be interested in
at some point in time got it and so as
you think
uh kind of moving forward how big is the
team today what will that
how will that change as uh as you
continue to invest in the product
so today the team is 116
people and it was i think back in
december
where we were at just about 70 people
and so it's just we've grow i mean we've
just grown so fast and we anticipate
that this thing is going to continue
throughout throughout 20
2021 and all the objectives that we're
gonna do with the secondary trading
systems
and uh making d5 easy and all these
sorts of things we anticipate by the end
of the year is is
very conceivably that we could be well
over 250 people
and so this thing feels like a rocket
ship and we're just we're
we're along for the ride and it's been
it's been a lot of fun i love it what's
the biggest
obstacle um that you're gonna face like
what's the thing that keeps you awake at
night as you continue to build the
company even though you've had all the
success
and uh things look very you know
positive looking forward what's the
thing that keeps you awake
the biggest thing right now is working
with the regulators to make sure that we
have a framework
that allows people to use these systems
and allows people to actually own equity
in companies
that's the biggest obstacle right now
and and we're you know we've been
working with the sec on this
and we're going to continue to work with
the sec on this and unfortunately it
seems that
as time goes on uh the regulators have
held
much more of an open mind about things
and so that's that's been great to see
but that's by far the biggest obstacle
is making sure
the regulators are comfortable with what
we're doing and how this is all going to
work
is the biggest obstacle yeah no it makes
sense and then talk to me about kind of
the team in general is it uh i know it's
remote but is it mostly us
is it international how is the uh kind
of team broken down
so most of the team is actually
international
we have 40 i think 40 some people
in the united states and the rest is is
completely international
but the cool thing is is that we pay us
salaries no matter where you live it
doesn't matter if you live in
a country with the lowest cost of
standard of living we still pay u.s
salaries
everywhere in fact we anchor our
salaries to the denver colorado market
and that and so we anchor it no matter
where you live because we don't want
somebody to get paid more
whether you live in san francisco or new
york or get paid less again
if you live in a very cheap place you
should be paid a fair wage wherever you
live and
another cool thing is we have 100
transparent salaries and 100 transparent
cap table
so everybody in the company can see what
everybody else is making
and so what that does is that allows or
that forces us as a company to be
aggressive and ensuring that our people
are happy
and not you know having to feel the need
to go get a job offer somewhere else and
then get some counter offer from us
because
every single person's salary is
transparent yeah
and how do you keep track of that like
is it just posted on like an excel sheet
somewhere
is there a dashboard like that's a
really fascinating way to look at kind
of
uh you know eliminating internal
politics
it's just on an excel spreadsheet but
one of our visions is to actually become
the most transparent company in the
world and so what that means to us
is that you know when we when we have
this regulation a public offering
and we become effectively a public
company
we don't want there to be any difference
between you know insider trading or not
we want everything to be public so the
moment
an event happens it goes up on a website
all everything that we're doing it goes
up on our website
so that we can be transparent about
everything and we've always found that
transparency is a part of our ethos
transparency
really brings in trust and i think
that's really important to
building a company i think it's very
important so i tend to uh tend to agree
with you
um before we get into the rapid fire
questions uh when people ask you what is
exodus just give us kind of the one or
two sentence pitch and then tell us
where
people can go to download the product
now exodus is the easiest to use
cryptocurrency wallet that allows you to
send receive and exchange
cryptocurrency you go to exodus.com to
view more or
exodus underscore io at uh twitter
that is a pretty concise elevator pitch
some tell us
about the first time you've ever done
that um i've got uh three questions for
you and you get to ask me one two uh to
finish up
the first question is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
most important book i've ever read is
how to win friends and influence people
that that book was definitely
transformative and how i approach
relationships
in both the professional realm and the
personal realm
um there's some outdated lines in that
book about
you know addressing people like mr or
mrs or whatever but overall there's
still some really great content in that
book
absolutely uh next question is a little
bit more uh
personal sleep schedule i used to sleep
five six hours but now i sleep like
eight or nine
uh and a huge part of it comes from our
friends over at eight sleep
uh and so their question is what is your
sleep schedule they've got this
thermoregulated bed which just means you
can make it really hot you can make it
really cold
i sleep on literally an ice cube uh and
sleep like a baby and my apple watch
tells me you know good job every morning
after i started using this thing i feel
like i'm cheating the system
what's your sleep schedule and how's
that changed over the years yeah so i
used to be one of those guys that i'd
stay up until five six seven a.m in the
morning in fact
my wife would come to my office and she
like you know my hair was all messed up
i was wearing sweatpants and a big furry
sweater
and uh she was like oh my god i can't
believe i'm married to this guy
but over the years and especially with
kobit around the copic time i started
like i've got to you know i got to fix
my sleep
and so i have started religiously going
to bed between 10 p.m and 10 30 p.m and
then i get up religiously between 4 30
a.m and 5 a.m every single day
yeah that they say that is one of the
biggest things even though you're not
sleeping eight hours we'll work on that
part of it
uh the whole idea of going to sleep at
the same time every night
is a is a major major factor of make
sure you get great sleep oh and it helps
with clear thinking you know as is
running a company you really got to be
thinking clearly and so
having good sleep helps with that
absolutely yeah makes uh makes sense
last question that you get to ask me one
to wrap us up is aliens are you a
believer or a non-believer
oh absolutely when i when i was a kid i
got so
wrapped up into you remember that show
unsolved mysteries with robert staff you
remember that show
oh my gosh i would watch you know all
the stuff about the ufos and i was i was
really
i actually got scared you opposed the
kid but but these days i'm no longer
scared of ufos but yeah i think it's
pretty improbable
to think that in the entire universe
that
alien life does not exist yeah i'm there
with you i think it's uh very unlikely
but who knows
uh just the big questions whether we'll
ever come in contact with them or not
uh what's the one question you have for
me to wrap us up
so back in the summer i think i remember
on one of the podcasts you said that you
owned i think
bitcoin only so since then
what are your top four assets that you
hold now
bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin and bitcoin oh
come on you don't you don't hold
anything
else still only bitcoin only bitcoin
that's it wow wow okay all right and
look and part of it is like
i'm not uh i'm not a trader right i am
not looking for the greatest financial
return
right you know so it's kind of like you
got to ask somebody like why
right and to me it's just it's the
simplest thing
right and it's still going to be pretty
attractive in terms of how it plays out
now in terms of investing right and
usually from my
professional standpoint i've missed all
kinds of stuff right and so
um you know really really fascinating
with decentralized open protocols
really interested in a lot of kind of
the governance things there's a whole
new kind of body of work around merge
mining on bitcoin
and spending a lot of time paying
attention to that right and so like
there's all this kind of innovation
that's occurring and so intellectually
i'm i'm
really really uh curious and i'm really
uh kind of
uh um kind of intrigued by it and so
spending a lot of time
you know understanding it learning uh
meeting all the people who are kind of
driving this
um but really personally the only thing
that i own is bitcoin it's the simplest
easiest thing i actually suggest that
for most people um and then the other
thing
is uh that's kind of tangentially
related uh is i have a lot of digital
art
right and i'm probably you know quickly
becoming uh
you know one of the larger holders of
digital art in the world and the thought
process there is just like i enjoy it
right
it's more of a game to me that's less of
like an investment it's more of a game
um and so it's just you know at this
point in my life it's just i just want
to do the things that make me happy
right if i'm happy then like whatever do
you anticipate buying any any other
crypto assets other than bitcoin or
digital art i mean i i never want to say
never
right just just because it's like you
know you'd be pretty stupid to say no
for forever um and you know there's
things that
uh i'm really really intrigued by it's
like i'll give you a perfect example
unit swap is a perfect
unit swap today is uh based on current
numbers
uh a little bit smaller than coinbase
right coinbase last year did 1.3 billion
in revenue
uh unit swap is somewhere between like
800 million and a billion
so even if you discount a little bit
let's say unisox would be like 50
of uh of coinbase well like there's
probably a pretty strong argument that
the decentralized product is going to be
bigger than the centralized product now
is the decentralized product going to be
uniswap is going to be something else
who knows who you know we'll see kind of
a lot of stuff but i do think that like
that stuff is really fascinating
the part that i keep going back to is uh
it seems like there's a lot of
innovation and really experimentation
happening around how do you do
governance how do you do like on-chain
cash flow do you need a token do you not
need a token like
all these different components to it and
so you know the beauty of this industry
is just all figuring it out like no one
has the answer yet everyone's got an
opinion
and so uh when i worked at facebook we
have the same you know code wins
arguments
yeah that's what we're watching play out
here in real life right it's like code
is gonna be the argument i love it yes i
love it
so i i think that uh that's kind of how
i look at it and you know i'm open to
other things it's just like i'm just
learning right now and then once i've
got a kind of a deep conviction like i
do with bitcoin uh then we'll go from
there
yeah i think a student mentality makes a
lot of sense
i'm not the smartest guy but uh but i
like to think that i am
intellectually curious enough to uh to
learn from everybody else so we'll see
how that plays out
awesome jp before i let you go where can
people go if they want to participate
in the uh in the uh reggae offering that
you're doing
exodus dot com forward slash invest but
if you just go to xs.com
you'll you'll figure out the rest from
there but exodus.com
awesome man well listen thank you so
much for doing this i really enjoyed it
and i think people will
learn a lot and uh i highly suggest
people go check out xs.com or search in
the uh the app stores for exodus it's a
beautiful
cryptocurrency wall and uh i think the
jpeg team did a great job and then
you know when you add in the bitcoin
ethos of uh paying everyone in bitcoin
being decentralized all that stuff it's
just uh kind of icing on the cake so
thanks so much man we'll do it again in
the future
absolutely thanks pop